so i've gotten a ton of emails lately
some from people gloating interestingly
enough which is kind of a weird thing
psychologically that's going on
saying david what is happening with your
stocks and bonds and what is happening
with your crypto and i'm so glad you're
losing everything and have you sold and
all these different things and indeed
there's been some uh pretty significant
market instability recently we've seen
um uh stocks in the united states down
significantly we have seen crypto down
significantly and i'm hearing from all
sorts of different people telling me
what they think i should do and others
asking me what it is that i did do
others saying see how stupid you were
forever having any crypto or whatever
the case may be
and i have to tell you
none of it makes a difference to me
my approach is
correct asset allocation
and staying in the market i don't think
very highly of my ability to project
what any market is going to do in the
future stocks bonds cryptocurrency i i
just don't think i'm i don't i don't
know enough i'm not smart enough i don't
think humans in general are good at
predicting markets so my approach is
let me if i can sort of understand the
level of risk that each asset class
represents
let me find an asset allocation that
makes sense for me and for me that means
because of my age i still have
most of my invested money in the
broadest based stock index funds
some in bonds stocks are split between
domestic and international
and about three to five percent in
cryptocurrency and in doing that i don't
really have to pay attention to what's
going on there's only one logical path
forward which i'll tell you in a moment
now just real quick i do want to tell
you about our sponsor start mail
their mission is simple
keep your private information that is in
your emails private when you use email
services from big tech companies the
services are free but you're paying for
it with the personal information that
you give them in your emails which are
scanned
and then they make money selling your
private information targeting ads to
that content
when i use start mail for email they
keep my emails private period they don't
scan my emails they don't profit from my
information any email i send to anyone
can be encrypted i can create unlimited
email aliases where i can receive emails
without giving someone my real email
address if i'm signing up for something
and switching to start mail was super
easy they let me seamlessly transfer all
of my existing email data don't let the
big tech companies go through your
emails and profit from your private
information you can go to start mail dot
com slash pacman to get fifty percent
off your first year take your privacy
seriously the link is right underneath
this video and that'll give you fifty
percent off your first year of start
mail so did i sell when stocks and
crypto crashed of course not
of course not
i continue to believe i have the correct
asset allocation for my risk tolerance
as well as my age and my time horizon
if i believe
that i should be three to five percent
in crypto and remember i've been in it
for six years it's up 10 20 30 x i'm i'm
exclusively playing with the house's
money at this point if it goes down the
little amount i have left compared to
what i had it what if if it goes down
why would i sell i just lose money
i don't know if it's going to zero
or if it's going to wherever but i'm
comfortable with that three to five
percent being in a risky asset i'm
holding cash 15 12 15
cash which is not at risk there's
inflation risk of course because it's
making almost nothing
in supposedly high yield savings
accounts
i have inflation risk there but the
principal is not at risk 12 to 15 is
right for me there and then as i
mentioned my stock bond portfolio
i'm why would i sell and take a loss in
fact i'm doing the opposite which is i'm
continuing to buy not buying the dip
which means you're committing extra
capital but when i do my buys once twice
a month i continue to do it regardless
of the value of the market at the time
because what else am i going to do and
case in point
there was this day
earlier there was this monday
where
stocks were down big in the middle of
the day and all these people were
tweeting me david you got to sell you
got to get out you got to get out and i
said do i i don't know where the
market's going from here
it ended up being an up day in the
market not that i pay attention to day
to day in this way but had i taken the
advice of people saying it's all the way
down from here
um i would have ended up with less money
because the day ended up on a positive
note so if you believe you know how to
time the market and pick stocks by all
means do it i don't have that level of
confidence and so for me it's asset
allocation
over the long term that matches my risk
profile and we'll see where we are in
six months and we'll see where we are in
a year if you have a different
perspective i would love to hear from
you